[Music]
oh let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not not
Liberty you [__] eating [__] ah the
smell of freedom of speech this is the
Tony Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them Republicans are in court today like
a mother
[__] oh my God every last one of
them's in court enrick tario he's going
to be sentenced today h we're going to
be following that Ken Paxton's
impeachment trial is
today apparently Mark Meadows is turning
on Donald Trump flipping on Donald Trump
not surprising that Mark Meadows is a
rat did you hear what Mark Meadows said
oh this guy said it out loud what what a
what a goddamn baby
what H how in the world did we not
understand how cowardly the Republican
party is how did we not understand for
like the last 30 years I'm not just
talking about like right
now I mean to give you some history of
Mark Meadows Mark Meadows was a
congressman and he was the founder one
of the founders of the freedom caucus in
the House of Representatives remember
the remember the old days when when
their fascism was dressed up as tea
party you remember that [__]
oh the good old days when they were like
yeah we're fascists but it's more like a
tea party type thing not exactly overt
nais are protesting in Florida at Disney
World not that kind of fascist I mean
that's where they are today that's what
trumpism is that's what they love oh man
they love them some Nazis now those
Nazis go to you know Disney World and
drag shows and they they shout
Republican policy points through a
bullhorn it's really good for the
Republican party it's good advertisement
for them
Mark Meadows Mark Meadows is such a
coward he literally said these words so
that he didn't the president of the
United States didn't yell at me I didn't
want him to yell at me he's so mean when
he
yells I'm not [__] you so when when
the when he was being um deposed in open
court he's trying to get his trial in
federal court down in Georgia let me
back up a
bit again I'm no attorney here um but
I'll I'll do my best to give you what is
easy to know in this case Mark Meadows
does not want cameras in a courtroom
that's what he that's what he doesn't
want he knows he's gonna go to trial in
Georgia right he knows that he's not
gonna get out he's not gonna slide out
of this
indictment and the reason why is because
fonny Willis has basically told Jack
Smith and whatever deal Jack Smith has
made with Mark meows to go [__] himself
I don't get fonnie Willis I don't know
if you know this she does not give a
single [__] not one not a [__] to give
not to any of these sons of [__] not
one she has no [__] left at all all out
been out for a while and she does not
give a [__] if Mark Meadows has a
deal she doesn't give a [__] if Mark
Meadows has a deal with Jack Smith and
the
FEDS mark Meadows cares because Mark
Meadows doesn't want to go to um
prison so what Mark Meadows is trying to
do is do the best damage control
possible because he knows he's gonna go
to trial in Georgia eventually at some
point mark Meadows is going to be on
criminal trial in the state of Georgia
now what he wants to do is he wants to
get it in a federal courtroom which he
essentially has at this
point he is now in a federal
courtroom his case is currently
temporarily a federal case in the
federal courtroom now it it there's a
lot of [__] legal [__] here right
fonnie Willis is still gonna prosecute
the case still has to file George state
law if he gets convicted he'll spend
time at a Georgia Penitentiary more than
likely but what Mark Meadows wants is no
cameras that's what he wants he wants to
be able to flip on Trump in court in
open court he wants to turn on him he
wants to [__] dunk on that son of a
[__] and say it was all his idea all
every [__] last bit of it was his
idea I had nothing to do with it all I
was doing was following orders just just
like the proud boys and the oathkeepers
this [__] is all coming full circle
isn't it on a day like today holy
[__] speaking of today like today not to
get off subject but we're gonna have
Fred Wellman at the bottom of the hour
he's going to talk about trumpers going
to prison that's right he's going to
talk about trumpers and veterans is
going to prison for Trump which is kind
of weird but he's going we're going to
talk to Fred about that I'm going to ask
Fred about some of the stuff that's
going on then we're going to textas Paul
on as we do every Tuesday and Gabe
Sanchez is gonna join us today too so
stay tuned don't go anywhere but back to
Mark Meadows he does not want cameras
when he flips on Trump and the reason
why is because again he's a [__]
coward always has been always will be a
coward mark tried to explain the reason
why he set up the meeting the phone
meeting the perfect phone call with Brad
ranburger on behalf of the campaign not
the White House on behalf of the
campaign when Mark Meadows was the chief
of staff he was not on the campaign
staff he was on the White House
staff and he said well the reason why
when they ask why he did that well
because he gets really mean and he yells
and throws ketchup and cheeseburgers and
I didn't didn't want him to yell at me I
mean that's a little bit of an
exaggeration but it's not much it's not
much of an exaggeration of Mark Meadow's
Cardis but this is who they are this is
who they are and Mark Meadows does not
want to appear on camera and he knows he
knows that there will be no cameras in
the federal courtroom there'll be
cameras in the Georgia one so he's
trying to stay out from him front of the
[__]
cameras he wants the mug shot to be the
only image into him being a convicted
felon for trying to overthrow our
government in
Georgia because that's what they did I
mean Jesus Christ we got oathkeepers and
proud boys getting terrorism
enhancements for the Insurrection on
January 6 the one that they [__]
planned with the state electors the fake
State elector scheme all the the fake
State elector scheme is an integral part
of the January 6
Insurrection that was part of it it was
part of their foot stol to try to
overthrow our government and take your
[__] vote and your way of life of
democracy away from
you and Mark Meadows was an integral
part of that rather he wants to admit it
or not no matter what deal he has with
Jack Smith or he doesn't he was an
integral part of it and he's ad
it in [__] federal
court this is big it's big when he says
well I did it on the behest of him
because he would get mad at
me which leads to the motive of Donald
Trump to direct people to go try and
overthrow the
government it's huge is it going to
matter like to Trump voters no is it
going to like prevent Trump from being
being the nominee
no is it a big step towards the [__]
truth yeah but do they give a [__] about
the
truth does oan Newsmax Fox News do you
think they're gonna [__] look at this
and go oh man that's some that's some
hard-hitting truth we better report on
that now they're probably going to be
talking about how Biden's trying to ban
ceiling fans and he took some imaginary
bribe that doesn't
exist and how big hunter Biden's [__] is
that's what they're going to talk about
they're not going to talk about they're
not going to talk about the actual
truth [__] you can barely get the
mainstream media to talk about the
truth or for them to admit the truth
hell I was listening to Morning Joe a
little bit this morning and they were
trying to drop some truth about the
actual timing of this Georgia trial or
if there is a trial and trying to
explain how complex these 19 cases are
and how long it's going to take to get
Donald Trump in a
courtroom because that's the truth of it
is it's G to take a long time folks
you're now he may get in a federal
courtroom I don't know I doubt it but he
may get in a federal courtroom by the
time the election happens next year he's
got a lot of delay tactics that he's
gonna that he's going to deployed to
stay out of a
courtroom a criminal courtroom a
criminal trial that is
he's going to deploy a ton of delay
tactics don't [__] think he's not and
don't think that he won't succeed at at
a certain good portion of them he
will that's why we have to stay vigilant
we have to keep our eye on the prize and
know that we are his jury not to give a
[__] about no criminal trial we're the
jury because he will be the
nominee let me tell you
something if this Mark meow's in federal
court basically saying I did this for
Donald Trump because he would be mad and
be a [__] little baby if I
didn't he would throw ketchup against
the wall if I didn't commit sedition for
him any other [__] any on any other
timeline on any other
timeline Donald Trump would be
done but it's a cult and we're not on
some [__] normal ass timeline here we
are at the intersection of WrestleMania
and real
life and this is the reality that we
have to deal with whether you like it or
not whether you like reality or not
right I I you know a lot of people are
going to get mad at me here so just
buckle up you're G to get pissed off at
me because I know a lot of you like
Glenn K Kushner a lot a lot of you like
him and I respect him and he's a smart
guy but Glenn needs to stop saying
stupid [__] he needs to stop this
morning he he always he always goes on
msbc says everything right until the
very end of what he's saying because I
know what he's doing I know what he's
doing he's trying to give you hope but
what he's doing is he's bowing down to
authoritarianism and he's talking about
he's talking about unilateral power this
morning Glenn released a video on
Twitter really stupid stupid stupid
stupid stupid the most the most anti- de
democracy thing I've ever heard Glenn
say that somehow some way we can we can
just sidestep the rights of a person in
this country no matter who they are to
to and the Secretary of State in a in a
state of wherever whichever state it is
the secretary of state has a unilateral
power of keeping someone off the ballot
because they don't like them that's
literally what he said he's like oh the
14th Amendment it totally totally the
14th amendment gives give secretaries of
State the right to keep Trump off a
ballot he is wrong he's [__] [__]
wrong I I want that to be the truth you
want it to be the truth Glenn knows that
so that's why he's saying
it we ha we we cannot we cannot stand
back and just let people run rough shot
over our Democratic institutions
especially democracy itself
folks you know the whole [__] about
Trump when he says if if they can do it
to me they can do it to you and we all
know that's [__] right if you have
two [__] brain cells to rub together
you know that's all [__] it's
backwards right if they can prosecute
you like maybe uh low-level proud boys
and oathkeepers for trying to commit
sedici you know treason against our
country then they should be able to
prosecute Trump if they can if they can
put someone in federal prison who was at
the violent Insurrection that day at his
Direction just going into the capital
and threatening people and they put them
in prison they should be able to put him
in prison too you got it you got it
rights extend to
everyone but also the right to be
innocent until proven guilty is super
important folks it is [__] crucial to
Law and Order now I know we have a
two-tier justice system I know the
justice system is not fair most people
of color in this country when they go in
the criminal justice system they are
definitely not assumed innocent until
proven
guilty and that there is a special
privileged tier for [__] rich
white people like Donald
Trump certainly those are facts but we
cannot trade away we cannot trade away
the thought that we can take his rights
away from him because if we do that cuz
that's what Republicans are clamoring
for folks oh my God that's what they
want so [__] bad that's what the
weaponization of government [__] from
Jim Jordan and James comr is about you
know that right they want to weaponize
government that's why they're saying
Democrats weaponize government because
they want to it is their [__] desire
to use the government to smash
descent and if we take away the rights
of
anyone even
Trump if we take away the rights and we
just use unilateral power our Trump try
to use unilateral
power right if we try to use unilateral
power at a state level where a secretary
of state can say hey you don't get to be
on a ballot because I don't like you and
I think you committed Insurrection which
we all saw it but he's not convicted of
it and Glenn tried to conflate it to an
age right he's like well if you're you
have to be 35 but if you're 34
you can't you can't be on a ballot
that's true because you have facts you
have facts in front of you to keep them
off a
ballot you don't have the facts in front
of you yet about Insurrection and I know
it feels good because people in Discord
right now are like ah no no no Glenn's
right Glenn's right he's not right if
Glenn was right he would already be 14th
on in many states this would already be
a thing
and you're going to watch it and you're
going to see it and he's going to end up
on those ballots just like I told you
that there's not going to be [__]
cameras in a federal
courtroom see and and and again again
it again again I tell you I understand
how bad and how dire our democracy is on
the [__] chopping block here I get it
but what you cannot do what you cannot
do is is go above and beyond
and use authoritarian unilateral power
because you want
to that's what they want to do folks
authoritarianism breeds authoritarianism
it does not matter which side is using
it it does not matter our democracy our
democracy is dependent on us us the
people the
people we have the power we have the
power of the ballot it is us and for you
to get and for you to get all excited
about something that Glenn says that's
all a bunch of [__] hoey because it
says something and it's not so clear and
it really isn't clear on what it can and
can't do no Secretary of State in this
country who is worth their
weight is going to keep someone off the
ballot that has not been
14th not going to happen it's just not
it's
not you can talk about it you can
fantasize about it but what you're going
to do is distract from the real [__]
problem the real [__] problem isn't
Trump he's just a symptom of it he's a
symptom of this
problem the problem we have is not Trump
when he's go long
gone and it's going to take many years
for him to walk through this criminal
process and his criminal trials and I
don't even know if he'll ever be locked
up who knows hell he might die of old
age before he gets
there but I'm telling you if you focus
on
stuff like cameras in federal courtrooms
and you focus on the 14th Amendment
you're missing you're missing where your
energy can be spent you're missing it I
promise you I promise
you
so don't buy the argument because it
makes you feel
good oh what what what why wouldn't I
want him 14 do you know how [__] do
you know how tremendous that would be do
you know how tremendous that would be
think about this think about how
tremendous it would feel right and this
is what Glenn is tapping into oh your
your feelg goods this is what the
rightwing does with with all their
audience too by the way this is why I
don't do this and this is why I speak
out in this way and again I I respect
Glenn he's a smart guy he knows what
he's talking about but he's completely
100% wrong in this aspect and I don't
know why he's saying it when I believe
he probably knows he's wrong and I would
have Glenn on the show and challenge
him challenge him [__] message him
and tell him I've talked to Glenn before
on a live broadcast I've asked Glenn
questions but I'm telling you this is
not the road that our democracy is going
to go down it's just not just like they
weren't going to get rid of Merrick
Garland because he wasn't Prosecuting
Trump you remember that I'll get rid of
Merrick Garland he's not doing his job
he'll never prosecute Trump he's trying
to protect him remember
that remember those good old
days [__] I could I could go back and
give you a hundred different
scenarios of what the outrage was and
what we're going do stop Trump what we
need to do to stop
Trump what we need to do to stop
Trump is to engage in democracy that's
what the [__] we need to
do that's what we need to do engage in
democracy not in
fantasy not to that like we're going to
expect secretaries of state to
unilaterally right to unilaterally take
him off the ballot because well he he
did this thing that he's indicted for
he's not convicted yet but he did that
thing because when you do that you are
you are literally taking away the right
of Innocence until proven guilty you're
taking it
away and let me tell you
something let me tell you something if
they can do it to him they will do it to
you that's for godamn
sure and we cannot sacrifice for the
rest of time our
democracy that we can just do whatever
we want because we don't like something
and we don't like what happened and we
don't have the things we need that our
constitution allows now you can talk
about changing the Constitution hey I'm
I'm all for that talk it's really stupid
that's a [__] that's a losing battle
right now too sh the Republicans can't
even keep government open they're going
to close it intentionally to be honest
and the reason why is because they can't
govern
anyways alls they want to do is talk
about impeachment when they can't even
impeach Biden they'd have done impeached
him if they could do
it they're all talk it's all
talk get to the
nitty-gritty get to what you can do
speaking of what you can do for your
democracy this morning Gloria Johnson
the state senator one of the Tennessee 3
she announced this morning that she's
running for United States
Senate now there's some [__] action
there's some [__]
engagement that's how you can
participate in your democracy right
there you want to change some [__] there
you go now you got
it that's how you can G you want to know
another thing you can do to gaug in your
democracy we're probably going to talk
CU we got Texas Pauling today I know
we're going to talk about [__] Ken
Paxton in Texas that crooked ass
[__] spending spending Texas tax
dollars on his lavish vacations sounds
like harlon Hitler and Clarence Thomas
type
[__] you you know what you should do if
you're in Texas you know what you should
do you should engage in your democracy
in this way phone a bonehead call your
[__] representative and say hey when
are we going to get a
refund for the money that Ken Paxton
spent huh when are we going to get that
[__]
refund you might not want to say it in
those words be
nice but ask when when are we going to
get a refund are you going to challenge
him when you impeach him are you gonna
vote to impeach it and once you vote to
impeach him are you gonna go get that
money
back because this morning just just
minutes
ago six Republicans now the news is is
that they dismissed are are they they
cast aside this dismiss missile of his
impeachment trial 24 to6 but the real
story is six Republicans are still
voting in favor of this crooked
[__] that's where we're at in
our
democracy fascism is on our doorstep
folks and they want to kill democracy
and they want to kill it now because
they know they've lost the culture
wars they know what is waiting for them
on the other
side of our voice
and our our power of the ballot they
know what's
waiting and it's not good for them it's
not good for their
ideology it's not good for their culture
wars that they want to have it's not
good because we're going to smash the
[__] out of them in
2024 as we should I mean we got an
election coming up here in 2023 in
Virginia which is a crucial
election we have to stay focused we have
to stay focused and we can't
continue to stay focused if we have
these little cute little shiny things
that aren't really real they're not
real he's going to be on a ballot the
Secretary of States are not going to use
unilateral power against a citizen to be
on a ballot and if they do they're wrong
to do
it it's a it's it's
wrong it's against our Democratic
institution and if you say you're Pro
democracy and you're you're for the
pro-democracy Coalition you should not
want a secretary of state to use
unilateral power like a republican
would because that's what they would do
that's what the authoritarians would do
we cannot use
authoritarian power to smash
authoritarianism and only breeds it
so stay vigilant out there the way you
can stay vigilant one way I think is
watch this [__] show every single
weekday Monday through Friday and how
you can do that is go to Subs go to dton
michaels.com and hit subscribe subscribe
at Theon michaels.com I send you updates
every morning on the show and and just
scan down on Theon michaels.com there's
all kinds of great stuff here that you
can get involved
in and we're going to have new
announcements things are going to change
we are expanding the show folks we are
doing expansions at the Tony Michaels
podcast that is right we are going to
lean into democracy we are going to lean
in to making sure that you engage and
engaging thousands more every single
week so we are expanding the show I know
everyone's been talking about three
hours
forever we need three hours we need
three hours we need three hours and we
are going to expand the show we're going
to have have that news for you in the
coming
days we're g to have news for you in the
days so stay tuned so one way you can
stay tuned is go to the Tony
michaels.com hit subscribe at the top of
the page also get in on the Discord chat
rather you agree with me or disagree
with me with what I say on the show go
over there disagree with me get in the
chat that's all I ask just engage engage
in your democracy and Discord is a great
place to do it let me put the link in
the chat here so you can go join Discord
it's where the chat never stops really
honestly and it's a better it's a better
chat let's face it if you if you can
place memes and GIF in a chat that's
where you want to be anyways isn't it I
know a lot of people like the YouTube
chat and you guys are here a lot of
people are on Facebook but you should
check out the Discord there's a ton of
good stuff over there and make sure
you're verifying when you go into the
Discord server if you want directions on
how to verify just go to the Welcome
Center when you join the Discord go to
Welcome Center tell you how to verify
it's very simple you just hit the check
mark and they'll get you verified over
there so they know you're a real human
you're not some kind of robot or bot or
Elon
bot just to make sure you're real
human and get in on the chat we got the
live chat going right now you can post
pictures of the food that you're making
and eating stuff that you make photos
that you take the best political memes
are the best memes that you can find on
the internet all over there on Discord I
appreciate it and make sure you're
subscribing to the YouTube channel right
here on the Michaels make sure you're
doing that um we're going to have we're
going to have Fred Wellman coming up I
believe I I think oh yes yes he is he is
he is coming in he's gonna be coming in
here really soon so we're gonna have
Fred Wilman and then when we get done
with Fred we're gonna have Texas Paul on
as we do every single Tuesday so stay
tight don't go anywhere I'm telling you
don't go anywhere you're not gonna want
to miss this episode we'll be right back
right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy P's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product paron blanket I've got
you covered paron blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup paron blanket will
protect you too paron blanket is made of
a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome wel welcome back to the
show we have a special guest today back
on the show Fred
Wellman happy to talk to him I got a
several questions for him but prompted
me to invite him on the show is
something he
said last week I believe it was Jesus
it's hard to know with all these
criminal Republicans going to court and
getting convicted and um getting
receiving prison sentences of course we
see this morning Enrique tario is going
to get one and it looks like Ken
Paxton's going to be impeached I cannot
believe six Republicans in Texas were
like yeah we we like that crooked guy
that's awesome he's so cool because he's
like one of the crooked ones uh which
this again I it prompted me to ask Fred
to come on the show about this
Republican voter and I I can't remember
the exact story behind it this guy was
caught and of course he's a he's a
legisla in the in Alabama he's a
Republican and he decided it would be a
good idea to commit voter fraud and and
let me let me tell you it's not like a
democratic Hugo Chavez little Jewish
space labor laser type thing it's
definitely a trumpism type thing so Fred
I'm glad to have you back on the show
welcome back my friend let's talk about
let's talk about criminal Republicans
shall we because they're in court today
like crazy like they're in court
everywhere yeah it's a flood man isn't
it it's kind of crazy is it yeah so
let's start though with this story
because the what the kind of spin that
you put on it because you're you're a
veteran yeah and and the spin you put on
it which I thought was interesting is
that we should just elect veterans to
office because we can trust all veterans
no matter what party or what kind of
ideology that they have and what you
were saying kind of alluding to in this
in this tweet was you were like that's
not necessarily working out the way we
thought right well it's interesting that
I I was invol there's a number of
efforts it's the classic story one thing
I know so start from the beginning I was
a veterans advocate for 10 years right
before that army officer for 22 um so
it's it's something I'm near and dear to
my heart I've spent most of my adult
life involved with the military veterans
world and there was a great movement you
know and of course the reputation of
military shot up to the roof during the
global war and Terror uh in the 2010s
there was all these different veter new
veteran organizations built fantastic
groups helping great Americans you know
who served their country and then of
course 20 2015 2016 came along and the
fers those fers started to appear and
and there was this this dream I think
there was a couple groups actually
formed and the idea was they had looked
at history and said look look at this
golden time of bipartisanship we had in
the 60s and 70s and 80s where you know
tip O'Neal would you know hang out and
have drinks martinis with uh with the
Republicans and the idea what they what
they came away with was well all these
guys who served in World War II in Korea
they had this common Bond of being
veterans that common experience and thus
they would work together across the
aisle as as as brothers and sisters and
it would solve all the world's problems
there's this huge push to elect more
veterans and one group actually endorsed
bipartisan elect endorsed people from
both sides and then you ended up with
Dan
khaw you end up it sounds like a good
theory doesn't it one the guy yeah it's
a great it sounds like a great Theory I
get it we want to believe all veterans
are heroes and my gosh they serve and
it's true but they also when the one
thing you learn in military science 101
when you're an army offic to take
military science is that we are a
reflection of the society we represent
and all volunteer Force even a draft one
is a reflection of the society and our
society is divided there's not this
magical thing where eight weeks of
training or 10 years of service 20
reservice suddenly makes you not an
average American in the end right and
and there are things that you know and
so unfortunately there's been a large
movement uh towards the right uh and
towards the the trumpism amongst the
veterans world and and were're not
immune from it I mean my God they
elected the you know the Navy SEAL um
the Mr the bottle opener guy I can't
remember his name anymore um but he was
one of the guys you know fighting the
transgender ideology in the military and
and it's just again trumpism is
everywhere and so this idea that
veterans people are always shocked when
a story comes out so back to that story
that guy that did that was an army
officer an army veteran I think his name
is Cole right and then his name cole
yeah Cole I think and and he committed
voter fraud by by L running in a
district he didn't live in you he lied
about where he lived okay I mean true
fraud I mean election fraud then he
voted using a wrong address I mean this
is this is what it shows let's not
forget there's an active duty major in
the United States Marine Corps currently
being tried or prosecuted for January
6th he broke into the capital and opened
the door for the you know push to pushed
a cop aside to open the door for January
6th riers an active duty United States
Marine Corp off off are stationed at
quanico Marine Corps Barracks the the
headquarters you you know so it is this
is a real thing so so I I do often say
look don't don't try and make sure make
believe that the veteran military world
isn't immune from all this that the
politicization that we face as a country
is real uh and and by the way it also
offers a threat and that's where we get
into things like Tommy tuberville saying
oh there's no white nationalists in the
military that's just politics you know
there it's like no I'm afraid there
really are white nationalist they really
are racists they really are terrible
people and this ain't new Timothy McVey
was a veteran okay I'm pretty sure he's
not a [__]
hero you know well I mean hey there are
some people in this country who would
consider him a hero at this point and
that's one of the problems that's what
that's the disease that we have right
and I think that's what you're saying
it's not that it's not that all veterans
are bad or veterans are bad they don't
deserve to serve our country in a
different capacity other than in the
military I mean absolutely uh uh anyone
in the military deserves to have the
chance to get on a ballot and represent
their constituents if they have if if
those constituent so choose for them to
represent them the problem comes with
this disease of trumpism right this and
this and it's this disease of
authoritarianism I watched this because
I got on Tik Tok during the pandemic
right um and I was pretty heavily you
know I was watching Tiger King everyone
was doing these things and I saw on Tik
Tok the one thing the trend I saw on Tik
Tok during the the election because uh
some military active duty even did not
like Joe Biden and they were believing
some of the lies that were being told to
them through social media whether it be
Facebook or Tik Tok and these people
would go on on their active duty
uniforms and they would make videos on
Tik Tock saying some really crazy
outlandish [__] about what they would do
are are their thoughts are their
political beliefs which someone
shouldn't be hampered from giving their
their opinion about something but these
people were doing it as active duty
military members in their [__]
Uniforms on the internet on Tik Tok and
a lot of them were losing were losing
their jobs and being discharged because
of some of this stuff because you can't
you can't do that inside of a military
and it reminds me of Mark Millie came
out in front of the microphone I think
twice in December of 2020 when Trump was
really leaning into the big lie after
the states had certified yep and Mark
Millie called on all active duty
veterans and told them your oath is to
document it is to the Constitution not
to a man and what what that told me when
Mark Milly was doing that um and I
appreciate his service to do that for
our country in that moment what it told
me at the time because I've never served
in the military I had family but I've
never served him what it told me was
that he knew amongst the ranks that
there was this idea that their oath was
to Trump not to the Constitution um and
that's the disease I think you're
talking about or I might way off base
here no it's it's it's again it is we
are the people we serve right and so
there are trumpets there are also
liberals it's funny how the the thing
that it's when I had these conversations
the thing people believe the least is
that actually are liberals too I get
attacked a lot especially Instagram like
there's no liberals in the military what
you can't be I don't believe I had a
lady way up my [__] in my Instagram last
week saying I think you're fake you
never sir because I don't know any
veteran who's a bleeding heart liberal
like oh girl you got to get out I mean
there it is it is about 5050 split it
it's just we don't talk about it we're
not in a cult and and so you do see um
this disbelief that there are both sides
but again one side is you know we don't
like tax policy the other side wants to
overthrow the government and so it is
it's hard to yeah we have real threats
we do know that there are white nashers
who join the military to get the
training we do know that there are
people who um are so deep into the Trump
and stuff and and extreme Christian
nationalism that's a huge problem as
well I mean they they serve I mean it
look the military is tradition
conservative organization I was a
conservative then I at least I thought I
was uh you know for my my lifetime of
service and you know it's it's the
nature of the Beast it runs conservative
right defense Hawk all those things
right but by the same token we can't
close our eyes and that's the real
danger I think is that the delusion that
our military and our veterans or
specifically our acud military are above
above the politics or not political also
leads to a desperate desperate attempt
to IGN
when the facts are telling us screaming
in our face that we have a problem and
and and and refusal to investigate
that's what the Republicans are doing
that's exactly what Tommy to was saying
like they call them white naist I call
them Americans who just want to serve no
we've got to recognize that's a real
threat that a politicized military that
someone who's willing to to Sher their
oath to the constitution in pursuit of
one a bigot or racist agenda or white
nationalism what do you want to call it
trumpism uh that that's a danger to our
nation in a real way it needs to be
investigated separate from the Pol
political aspect of it but the problem
is we've got the Republican party has
made it oh they're just investigating
Trump supporter like no no we're
investigating the ones who want to
overthrow the government they just have
to be Trump it's just like it's like
somebody said you know I don't think I
don't know if Ronda Santa what what his
opponent say he said I don't know if
Ronda Sant is a racist but the racist
think he's a racist right well I I said
the other day I said I don't I don't
know if I don't Ronda santz does not
think he's a Nazi but the Nazis sure as
hell think sure think he is
is a is and it's not a problem it's not
a problem in um in the context of our
overall country it's a problem with the
Republican party because I think I think
when they when they say this talk about
Civil War right because you see you see
these uh these Trump allies and Trump
being indicted time and time again being
arrested he's like never surrender as
he's surrendering it's really [__]
weird right it's really weird but here's
the thing is that um it really the Civil
War seems to be happening and the the
biggest divisions in this country seem
to be happening inside the Republican
party because you said something that
has been sticking with me this whole
time you said I thought I was a
conservative which in all reality there
is a a a capital l liberal which I
consider myself a capital l liberal and
someone who believes in Liberal lower L
democracy and when someone actually goes
and gives their their their life because
when you are signing up for the military
you are giving your a lot of freedom and
rights away to be a member of the
military and you're doing it by taking a
a oath to a Constitution which is a very
liberal document um when it comes to
rights and freedoms because you're
saying I'm laying my life on the line to
protect rights and freedoms of people
that I may not agree with i i because
you are giving your life for for a what
we would call
Nazi to stand on a street corner and to
protest you are giving your life for
their right to do that and now the hate
speech that's a whole another level of
stuff but for them to protest and for
them to hold those beliefs you are
fighting for that right as Despicable as
that may feel or sound just as well as
you are fighting for the right for
someone to love who they want to love
and to be who they want to be rather
they're lgbtq or what whatever the case
may be your religion um whether you have
it or you don't you're fighting for all
those things and that's what liberalism
at its core lower L liberalism is is
that you're fighting for those choices
of democracy and opportunity um and
you're giving your oath and your life to
that oath which isn't that the
disconnect that we're having isn't that
the disconnect there it is in a lot of
ways again the the Cornerstone of
everything you just said is an
apolitical military right right I'll
tell you I'll tell you a story from Iraq
uh so I served with the organization two
tours the organization train the new
Iraqi military I sered under General
Petraeus actually Four generals which is
tells you how long I was there um and we
were training the Iraqi Army in in much
of our M we want the want the Iraqi
people to be assured no matter what
their religion or their or their or
their background that they were
protected by their their federal army
same thing as here right and and one of
the things we used to see quite a bit of
is the that the we would visit when I
would visit a base the Shia troops Shia
units um had a habit of putting stickers
or adornments on their military vehicles
of their Shiite um profits which is
something the Shia religion does versus
the Sunni Sunni does not have displays
of their prophets or of of course of of
Muhammad but on the Shia side they do
have different profits they they put up
pictures of right and uh but put them in
their military vehicles and and we were
ruthless about peeling those off and and
and and commanders be punished why why
is that why is why why is that for a
very simple reason we didn't want the
Iraqi Army to roll into a village that
may have been Sunni or kurd displays of
their religious icons on their Vehicles
leaving those people the impression that
these guys were not Ser would not serve
them when the time came because they
were of a different religion it's no
different than here I don't want people
running around remember the there was a
scandal during the 2016 election where
there was a Navy SEAL Convoy a National
Guard Navy SEAL Convoy in Florida that
had Trump flags flying off their
military vehicles and every a lot of
people didn't understand why it was so
scandalous it was scandalous because the
idea that we would fly military ve a
military vehicle would fly an actual
Trump flag at the time actually I think
actually it was after he was elected and
the argument from the right was oh
they're just supporting their president
I don't [__] care right we don't we
don't do that we don't we don't we don't
we don't have any kind of political
support and you know it was a campaign
flag and I was one of the people
screaming the loudest about that we
cannot have if the people don't believe
that the United States military will
serve them no matter who they are no
matter what the moment that when when
I'm in a disaster they're going to show
up no matter how I voted and save us
then we've got a big problem as a
democracy are very few things that I
call so fundamental to our democracy and
the reason this country has existed for
almost 250 years one of those is a
political military and where did it come
from it came from the king's troops
occupying our houses and you know and
serving through the king we we literally
have to have this and it it it is scary
for those us who gave their lives to
service I joined at 17 I wasn't even old
enough when I went to Bas I was still 17
um and then served until my in my 40s 20
total total 26 years in uniform and for
those of us who gave in my case
literally half my life to service in the
military it is horrifying horrify and by
the way we'd be having the same
conversation if they're running around
with [__] Obama stickers okay I'm
not I'm saying it is important that
neither side gets those right right um
and so it beca it's become this last
five to six years eight years now Jesus
time flies how scary that is you know
and and when you've got a
commander-in-chief or a former
commanderin-chief who literally said in
a in a an engagement that he likes
people that weren't captured and then
he's honored by groups that support PS
and miiaa he literally said he doesn't
like people are captured you know we
we've set through a Looking Glass and
that's why Flash Forward to today the
idea that just be the idea because
someone served that they are GNA be
bipartisan or they're going to be more
American no we're just as infected as
the rest of society and we also have to
be just as ruthless in pushing that back
and so yeah Millie stepping forward his
thing he gets beat up politically but
they had to we have to stop this
infection so what so what so what do we
do about the infection the cognitive
dissidence as it is um inside some of
our not just our military ranks but even
some of these groups like you said that
watch Donald Trump say if someone's
captured they're not a hero and then
they're like no PS are heroes what do we
do how do how do we get around that
cognitive dissidence and treat that
disease as we're calling it here I mean
how do how do we do that do we do that
with policy or is it done um through
Society where you know again you brought
up Timothy McVey of course he was cast
out as a domestic terrorist as he should
have been when he bombed the building in
Oklahoma City um but people are holding
him up as a hero again right like how do
we get rid of this cognitive dissonance
do we do it through narrative do we do
it through messaging is it a policy
problem what where do you fall on that
yes I mean all those things there's no
one answer it's like any kind of
strategy there's no one single ta work
we do have to be ruthless in enforcing
the regulations the policies of the
military we have to have politicians are
willing to to say these are unacceptable
behaviors and they have to be the
problem we've got is that as long as
it's on their political side what the
ACT is and they're going to defend them
um the the perfect example of this
there's no more better example this
entire conversation than the politics
you're still trying to get those who
refuse to get the coid vaccine back in
the military U they refuse to direct
veral War when you join the military you
get 17 to 19 shots and they don't choice
right there's no choice right it is what
it is but somehow the co vaccine was too
far and we still have politicians trying
to get these people who refused to
follow a lawful legal constitutional
order back in the military again we
politicized every [__] thing to
include a [__] shot for a deadly
disease that killed over a million of
our fellow Americans so we have to have
policies that are ruthless I applaud the
military for ruthlessly kicking those
people out and they should have been and
then and then keeping them out we need
to be ruthless in ensuring that when
these rear their head that the line is
set very strong within the military but
on the political side we have to be
ruthless and and holding these Pol
politicians accountable and saying no
unacceptable that's why the danger of
Tommy tuberville's hold on these
military promotions is so bad he is
ruthlessly and ridiculously politicize
the he's still doing it today just
saying the word abortion abortion
abortion and it has nothing to do with
evil he has used instead of doing his
job as a senator filing a bill filing an
amendment holding a [__] hearing
whatever whatever it takes getting 30 or
40 of his colleagues to go along with
them so they can actually have some
power and do the proper process this guy
is using the most ridiculous Norms
Traditions practiced against a policy
which is it's not how we're supposed to
be done and then the weakness and the
effectless of McConnell and the other
Senators Republican Senators to stop him
shows how far they've gone they're all
lost they're so afraid of crossing the
anti-abortion types they won't do the
right thing for the military so no I
don't have an answer Tony I wish I could
say oh yeah we gotta do this exact thing
right
here the step by step if we if we could
figure that out we would have done that
you know years exactly otherwise we
wouldn't be having these conversations
you and I got our jobs get that you know
it might not be a bad thing when we get
to a point in this country where we
don't have [__] to talk about people who
love me love me to get a real [__]
job at this point but you know I don't
think I can get hired I'm un hble but
you know seriously though it's it's
there is no simple answer I do believe
that there is a there's a policy
prescription to this and there is a
messaging and a political subscription
to this and there's an effort by us as
average of marage be to not be
acceptable and again it is a both sides
thing we can't just say well it's okay
on this side it's okay on that side
there is but but our the other side the
Democratic side isn't trying to do the
liberal side right right you know it's
like they're not trying to you know make
things you know make things illegal
they're not trying to support those who
are insurrectionist I mean we should be
deeply troubled the number of veterans
who appeared at on January 6 well I mean
some of them the oathkeepers Stuart
rhods is a veteran the oathkeepers the
whole point of the O Keepers they and
look by the way let's be very clear when
did the oathkeepers get formed wasn't
Trump right Obama that was a reaction to
Obama The Oath Keepers formed during
Obama I was still in the military when
the oathkeepers started okay were you
ever recruited by the oathkeepers like
ever approached Obama oh yeah they came
to me early on they won US it was it was
former civil military and former law
enforcement or active actually who
formed the oath many active uh I started
off as a group and we're not going to
forget our oath to the country right but
it was a that was anti-obama um right
well you know I actually I've actually
interviewed Dakota Adams Stuart rhs's uh
son a strange son and I've interviewed
his exwife and you know through that
interview I learned that Stuart roads
what was incredible through that that
that journey of that interview with them
is Stuart rhods in the beginning he
really tried his best to his credit to
keep white nationalists out of the
oathkeepers because he knew what it
would do and then when Trump came along
it was so easy and so fast to recruit
people with white Christian nationalism
and trumpism that he forgot all about
those risk and it led him to be
sentenced to 18 years in prison for
sedici conspiracy which is incredible
and and and we're gonna see uh Enrique
tario be sentenced today from the proud
boys which you know what's funny about
that too what what Dakota and and Tasha
Adams told me about Stuart rhods and
enri atario and the proud boys St roads
hated the proud boys hated and the
reason why is because because steuart
rhods always wanted to just not be
outfront and be a vocal voice but the
proud boys always wanted the glory right
they always wanted the glory because
they're they're white Christian
nationalists right so they they've
always wanted the glory but I just if we
can find you know and I know it's not a
simple solution but don't you think if
the problem that you're talking about
and this is the reason why it intrigued
me the reason why I want to have you on
is this point here is if we can actually
find a way through maybe policy but more
the political part The Narrative um to
get Society to be on the same page if we
can cure the disease inside the military
amongst veterans and active
duty don't you think that that might be
the same solution throughout the country
for trumpism in general is that is that
fair to say or I think it's there
there's there's science behind that I
mean one of the things we say quite a
bit in the military is again the
military is a micros of of our society
in large we get a lot of attention and
and because of that like homelessness
veterans homelessness well lots of
people are homeless uh PTSD uh the
science shows that about 8% of PTSD
suffers are actually military things
it's a military exclusive thing it's not
it's it's it's anyone so but by the
efforts to solve within the military and
the veteran Community we end up finding
solutions for the larger larger society
as a whole and often they trickle out
you know so so yeah there is there is
there is a history to show that if we
could figure this out within within our
military and with the challenges they
have but by the same token the military
has unique tools that General Society
doesn't you need the military has the
UCMJ this is a constant problem we say
with the police right the difference
between the police and the military is
the military has the uniform Cod of
military Justice and punishes their own
with the entire military system and a
set of rules that not only is it like
they'll lose their job they'll lose
their freedom if you break the ucj you
can go to jail right whereas with
unfortun on our police side they don't
have that sort of thing the the the the
the blue wall you know if a guy breaks
breaks the worst rules well he'll get
fired and then go to a different city
and get a job again right um and so it's
not as self- policing so the military
has unique tools they can use the rest
of society can't they have to have the
courage to use it the problem is even
that's becoming politicized right that
the punishments the example we gave
earlier of the of the vaccine mandate
was a perfect example they are punished
on the UCMJ and our far right trumpy
politicians politicize that process as
well so yeah we if we can solve that and
say and stop the hammering the military
and stop it look I I I still am an
optimist I believe the the system will
hold the system has hold held but it's
not going to be without danger it's not
going to be without some bumps U there's
going to be some terrible people will
pay a price for it um you know our show
last week I had I had rex hupy on the
show and and you know they talk about
the Civil War talk going back all the
very beginning of our conversation look
the Civil War is not going to be I I
just laugh every time some dumb [__]
talks about well georg's gonna georg's
gonna suceed like the [__] no states are
succeeding you dumb [__] especially the
ones that are on the federal Dole
especially it's gonna be it's gonna be
like Iraq okay it's gonna be like my
experience in Iraq it's gonna be cells
it's gonna be Timothy MC Timothy McVey
thought he was a rebel he thought he was
a he was an Insurgent it's gonna look
less like a Civ I think calling it a
civil war is the exact wrong term the
term we should be using is Insurgency my
friend Malcolm n uses that term that
these are insurgents these are
terrorists right and they can do a lot
of very few people like oathkeepers or
power boys or the ones we don't even
know exist because they're keeping it
very quiet are very ad waen Adam Wen is
another one yeah so Fred this is a great
conversation I'm so glad you had it one
last thing before we go we got about
three or four minutes tell me give me
give me your T your your rundown of some
of the criminal what do you think you
think in raro is gonna get over 20 years
Stuart Road got 18 Joe bigs got 17 do
you think the Judge is gonna give him
over 20 do you think what what's your
prediction I don't know not I I don't
pretend to be a lawyer by any stretch
imagination I don't see anywhere going
no way he doesn't get less than 18
though um I mean and again he's he's has
a history of this so he I think him and
S rhods are going to spend a lot of time
together um by themselves uh and prison
and and and I I love hearing the stories
they're not even popular that the white
nationalist don't even like them in
prison because they're not white
nationalist enough um you know you know
so it's it's um it's hated by everybody
it's just an unfortunate thing I
honestly I I almost I almost shed a tear
um when I Stu my toe the other day I
don't give a [__] about these guys they
come well you know you know you know
what speaking of crying in courtrooms
before we go because that's one thing
about Joe bigs Jo Joe bigs gave me um
Joe Joe bigs gave me calls to laugh
because he was crying in the courtroom
about his daughter and and all this
stuff he had none of that forethought
when he was committing sedition H but
then after the judge left the chamber he
yelled Trump won um so it only it only
tells me that everything they say is
[__] it's all [__] they don't
believe anything they have no principles
and that's that's the disease we're
talking about here that's the disease is
they have no core principles in our
democracy so Fred I appreciate you
question now Texas Paul had a question
oh okay what what do we got here chat
man uh i' like to ask for a question
about uh okay Texas Paul wants to come
on here here Texas
Paul I to see Texas fall in first we've
never appeared together yeah there
momentous day yeah it's historic so what
what's your question uh Paul oh man you
know I i' I did a I did a piece right
after January 6 I was like because
everybody was like well who the hell are
these groups this that the other and I
was and I was like look the proud boys
are idiots
they're freaking idiots I mean Enrique
tario went from on like November of
2017 uh being at a Milo yannopoulos uh
rally being introduced to a proud Boy by
one year later he was running the
organization I mean it was they were
just a loose they bunch of idiots right
the oathkeepers you know I'm like okay
look let's raise the red flag a little
bit because they're recruiting former
law enforcement they're recruiting
current law enforcement but they're
recruiting in the military they're
recruiting people with skills let's
watch that group they're dangerous but
then the first amendment petorian
guard came on the radar and nobody talks
about these guys and these guys are
pardon my expression [__] dangerous
these guys are seals these guys are
people with real fcking skills you
remember um uh during January 6 they
talked about the idiots from uh the
oathkeepers that had the guns in the
hotel room and then they all went to the
Olive Garden right one of the 1A prian
uh petorian guards was doing
OverWatch on that location they had done
the the Intel work to know that these
some [__] were doing this I mean
better than the damn government did Y
and they had somebody watching them and
what they were I don't know what their
intent was there but what have you I
mean that scares the [__] out of me Fred
and that's where I'm going with this is
when you get these highly skilled people
like that being recruited into these
right-wing organizations man it's like
okay not just red flags I mean [__] I'll
run naked down the street if you'll pay
attention to what I'm saying man I
mean you get where I'm going yeah I'm a
group so I'm involved a group called
Veterans fighting fascism uh task force
Butler a guy named Chris Goldsmith if
you if you're not following Chris
Goldsmith uh on all the different social
channels you're missing out Chris has
appeared actually appears on our Network
he appears on my touch Network on a
regular basis uh and has organized a
group of veterans like us to actually
infiltrate and and pursue these guys
find out who they are Expos their
Anonymous names and and and and hand
over they've done two research projects
on two organizations like that and
actually handed massive 300 Page files
over to the FBI so there actually are
people both private and of course our
federal government guys pursuing these
guys because you're right they're
they're incredibly dangerous I mean that
that is what I'm saying that that the
danger that the Civil War talk people
get people get focused in the Civil War
but really it's in
uh it's it's Terror not stochastic
terrorist not just words these are
actual people who have the means and the
and the training and and access to the
materials to actually kill people uh at
some point we should be afraid of that
and I I agree and uh it's why I do such
good try to do decent opsec on my own
personal life right because I've gotten
threats but there are groups and I'm you
should check out Chris gold Smith's work
Chris with the K uh and and what he's
doing is just that is these groups are
monumentally dangerous that they see
themselves as a defender of our
democracy in a way that and and and
fooled and look I I use it a lot people
sck if you watch my show I talk a lot
about 1920s Germany not 1930s joury the
big mistake are people oh this is like
the 30s in Germany no no the the real
danger is the 20s and the 20s between
the beerall poo and Hitler taking power
was when they they incited violence in
the streets they fought the Bolsheviks
and they broke glass and they they LED
riots they use the brown shirts as their
as their you know their their petorian
guard sound familiar and to to cause
vience and and that chaos is what led to
the idea that they could save it that
the fascist rise was because they were
going to put an end to this violence
right and uh it's like Star Wars I think
right it's
weird the story is always the same right
and this is a historic story so anyways
yeah I I take those guys very seriously
I take their threats very seriously we
should um by the same token we have we
should have faith there's not that many
of them but it only took Timothy McVey
himself to blow up a federal building
and kill a lot of people including
children um and I I hope and pray our
federal government is taking seriously
Unfortunately they are being stopped at
every turn by our own politicians the
Republican politicians um you know like
I said have you seen Donald Ronda sandz
has said a [__] thing about the Nazis
praying the streets minor minor
statements he is somebody said the other
day they compared the number of times
he's attacked um Librarians or others
versus versus Nazis uh he talks about
Librarians more he talks about Nazis and
and that's all you need to know that
there are PE there are politicians
believe this is their base uh and that's
just as scary any day as these guys run
around the cosplay milary you know Fred
I don't mean to like like push fear and
stuff like that I I actually do the
opposite of that on my show most of the
time I do and I you know it's like look
don't worry about eena Canon don't worry
about this it's GNA be all right and
this is why yeah this is just the
opposite we're getting like ra no radio
silence on these groups and these are
people that we
trained how to conduct insurgencies they
know which infrastructure to attack they
know how to attack it they know how to
cut off your gas supply for a week and
believe me your gas supply is cut off
for a week man we fall back to the Dark
Ages you know I mean they know exactly
which infrastru which in and nobody's
talking about these and I don't know if
they're not talking about them because
they're taking them seriously or they're
not talking about them because they're
not taking them seriously and that keeps
me up at night you want to know who's
talking about these groups um the Nazis
down in front of Disney World world uh
they had signs free this person and free
the peoples or pipes they didn't spell
people right I don't I'm not really sure
they can't spell but they wanted to free
the Adam lafin who attacked the U the
power grid do you remember this last
year those are the people they want to
free those are their those are their
political Heroes is the people who were
attacking our infrastructure and our uh
politic Fred thanks so much for coming
on come back again I I appreciate the
conversation about the military I know
see you Fred it might it might it might
not uh be the most comfortable subject
and it might piss some people off but
it's a thing that we have to keep
talking about because I I think the
problem you're right the problem is
there inside a society um as the
military is kind of a reflection of that
so thanks for going on everyone Fred's
link tree is down in the description
below make sure to go follow Fred uh
watch his podcast and follow him
everywhere everyone stick around we'll
be right back as they say on the radio
right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed because there's no good way to
keep them from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes Mak it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show Fred
Wellman go follow Fred again the link
tree is down in the description below if
you're on YouTube don't forget to
subscribe while you're here on YouTube
go over to the Discord get over on the
Discord they streaming live the Ken
Paxton proceedings this morning I know
me and Texas Paul are probably going to
get into a little bit of Ken taxton talk
what you should do is you should phone a
bon head though if you're in Texas if
you're in Texas you should phone your
representative and ask them very
politely very niely are we gonna get
reimbursed for all that money that Ken
Paxton stole from the state of Texas are
you gonna vote to impeach him and do
something about getting reimbursed for
that I don't know Texas Paul what what
are you seeing right now um
there for for Ken
bton I tell they're taking a little
break right I've been watching all
morning that's what I've been I you got
to forgive me Tony normally I watch your
show before I come on religiously so
that I can just jump right into the
conversation this morning they they you
know the impeachment has started and uh
Paxton just threw a just a blizzard of
of uh uh motions out there that they had
to vote on I think it was 18 of them
that they had to vote on that were just
but dismiss this charge dismiss that
charge um you know I mean just uh um
just he he filed a motion that was going
to try to force uh this Texas Senate to
provide him all the details of each
charge that was going to be tantam out
just to the evidence in the trial I mean
it was just crazy man and you talked
about the six there were six the six six
man Lois Kor Bob Hall Paul bet I'm gonna
make these some [__] famous Tony I'm
gonna make them famous Brandon kraton
tan Parker and and Donna Campbell Donna
Campbell she she's a real nutball down
in you remember where they attacked the
the the Biden bus down in new bronsville
Texas that's Donna Campbell's District
that right she is a nutball and they
just love her down there but you know
what it's actually it's not just the 66
it's the dirty 10 because there were
some others that floated in and out on
votes that that that came in there was
Charles Perry Kevin Sparks Charles
schwarner and Brian Birdwell also don't
think I forgot you guys I'm gonna come
see you I'm Gonna Make You Famous I
promise you well and again that's that's
where you can phone a bonehead H you can
get on the phone and call these your
repres if you're in Texas call these
representatives and ask them very polite
and very nicely why they voted the way
they're voting and why they're voting
against against democracy
uh and a and for a crooked
politician it seems in Texas he's about
to be impeached I I I have to um there's
a little bit of cleanup I have to do
here anna sent a venmo chat and I
appreciate Anna sending this vinmo chat
uh sh it was about the conversation I
was having about the 14th Amendment and
what Glenn said about the 14th Amendment
uh in the in in the intro here your take
on using the 14th didn't you say we
should Jerry Mander the cramp out of our
District so that Republicans stop seems
like you're arguing the other side now U
not that I don't agree with you and I
think she continued to say uh lots to
think about here so Anna it is different
here's why it's different um when I was
calling for people to Jerry Mander
districts it was in Democratic states
I'm calling for Democrats and Democrat
controlled states to gerrymander
districts which is a possibility it's a
good possibility it's a thing we should
do you can't you cannot have a secretary
of state use unilateral power there is a
difference between using using your
Democratic institutions uh to to
gerrymander districts but you cannot use
you cannot use a authoritarian or
unilateral power as a tech Secretary of
State as a state officer for that state
um to just take someone off the ballot
because you don't like them so there is
a difference and I get What Glenn is
saying I understand what he's saying
because it feels good because Donald
Trump should never have been on a ballot
as far as I'm concerned but that doesn't
mean he can't be and he he won't be
right I mean I my personal opinion is
that [__] shouldn't have ever
seen the inside of The White House at
all even as a visitor he shouldn't have
been but that's just because it's my
opinion doesn't mean that that's going
to happen it feels good to hear that
kind of thing but he's not going to be
14th and there's no Democratic secretary
of state that is going to go out on a
limb and take him off a ballot because
they don't like him I just don't see
that happening and the reason why is
because Democrats typically follow the
law and what I'm calling for Democrats
to do is Jerry Mander legally in
Democratic states not to play not to be
nice about it to to legally Legally
using their the the constitution in
those States just like Republicans do
all the time not like Alabama Alabama
this morning uh Gabe Sanchez is joining
us this morning Alabama uh a federal
judge said hey guess what you can't
ignore our [__] our our court order
because here's what we're gonna do we're
actually we're actually gonna assign
someone to now redistrict the state for
you because you won't [__] listen to
our our federal court order so again I
understand what Glenn is saying but what
I'm saying is is what he is saying is
authoritarian in nature it's not for
Democratic institutions it's against
Democratic institutions and when Trump
says they're coming if they come after
me they can come after you it's the same
backwards thinking it's the same
backwards thinking we as pro-democracy
Coalition should not be thinking
backwards we should be thinking forwards
and using our Democratic institutions to
protect Democratic institutions so I get
your sentiment and I know what you're
saying I know a lot of people are mad
that I did and I'll play the [__]
video from Glenn if you want to listen
to I don't give a [__] we can play it
after we get past the Paxton talk and
the Enrique tario talk but I I don't
have a problem playing it because when
you when you listen to
it Glenn he's a smart guy but what he's
saying in the video is not real it's
just not it's not going to happen and
and and for you to believe that it's
going to happen he's only doing that uh
to get you to believe that it could
happen and I know what he's doing trying
to get you to feel good about it but
that's not proper way to to to prop up
Democratic institutions it's just not so
yeah I just wanted to clear that up so I
appreciate the venmo chat from Anna and
thank you for giving me your your take
on things because folks hey if you want
to get in vinmo chat and you want to get
up on screen and you want to challenge
me go ahead I am all for it let's do it
well I'll I'll I'll get challenged like
I said I'd have Glenn on and I challenge
him to his face and he could challenge
me to his face I'd do that I'd 100% do
that um Texas Paul you were pointing
fingers oh man I'm just I I want to
thank you Tony I want to thank you thank
you thank you this has been just
enraging me this talk about they're just
going to kick people off the ballot
Trump did it we believe he did it and
that's it
[__] you cannot do that if you even
saying that opens the door for
Republicans to do that [__] that's right
cannot do that Trump has not been
convicted yet he is innocent he has been
innoc he is innocent till proven guilty
I think he's guilty as [__] you think
he's guilty as [__] we all agree he's
probably going to be because these
charges are so straightforward going to
be found guilty but thank you my friend
thank you I was so pissed off that was
all over that did did you see how viral
that went well that's because it feels
good Texas Paul went viral because it
feels good oh it makes you feel good it
gives you it gives you a anti-trump
boner and that's not that's that's all
great and all I I agree that oh yeah we
should make people feel good but we
shouldn't live in a state of delusion
it's ridiculous that's what they do we
should not be participating in states of
delusion I told you this about several
things Canon being dismissed or are are
recusing herself a didn't happen didn't
happen ain't going to happen Canon is
the judge man that's what's going to
happen listen here's the other thing
cameras in federal courtrooms not going
to happen it ain't going to happen no
matter how much you tweet it no matter
who says it no matter who goes on MSNBC
is like yeah I'm Neil Cel I like to wear
little helicopter hats and go to [__]
Burning Man and get stuck but I think I
think what we should do is have cameras
in courtrooms and federal courtrooms
it's not a thing it's not a thing and we
don't have the mechanisms to make it
happen okay that is what that is what
Republicans do is operate in total
[__] delusion I mean Jesus Christ
they're running around on Fox News and
Newsmax talking about how Biden's gonna
ban ceiling fans you want to get down
that road do you want to go down that
road of delusion to where we're talking
about [__] that doesn't even exist no we
don't want to do that as pro-democracy
Coalition we want to stand for our
institutions of democracy is what we
want to do and we want to trust
ourselves and Trust the people here um
to to to use the power of the ballot to
advance and progress our country towards
a more free diverse and inclusive future
that's what we want to do that's my goal
at least and if I could add one more
point to that just one
just I missed you Gabe I really missed
you man I have missed you brother it is
so good to see
you yeah and everyone everyone to be
here everyone in the chat's really mad
at me because they're saying no 14th it
does not require conviction yeah but it
does require a federal judge yeah it
does require a federal judge a secretary
of state doesn't just get to go yeah I'm
going to 14th this person because you
start doing that Republican secretaries
of state are going to do the same
[__] thing people you have you
been paying attention to what they're
doing in Tennessee have you been paying
there's there's [__] almost a dozen
Republicans down in Texas today like
yeah can Paxton he's my kind of crook
That's my kind of crook Ste you're gonna
get a conviction by this spring you're
get a conviction by this spring and then
they can act once he's been convicted of
a felony then they can start to act how
what what leads you to believe that
they're going to get a convection by the
spring on what grounds and where and
what we we've got I don't know we've got
a couple we've got a couple I didn't I
do know we've got several judges that
have decided we're not going to delay
these trials we're not going to drag
these out chuin is saying no we're we're
going to do this we're going to do this
she she set a court date for October I
think of 2024 or something I don't
remember there's been so many let me let
me writing them down well let me push
back on you just a little bit and here's
why and this is exactly what I'm saying
about um getting hopes high for
something that may or may not happen and
the only reason why I'm saying this
folks is because the narrative in the
country is going to be imperative next
year during the general election Donald
Trump is going to be their [__]
nominee and there ain't a damn thing
you're going to do to stop them from
doing it not a damn thing you're going
to do from stopping the Republican party
and these M maglites from choosing
Donald Trump as their nominee you're not
going to do it he and and by time we get
to Super Tuesday which is March 5th he's
scheduled to start his federal trial for
DC on March 4th it won't start then I
know it feels good to figure that oh
yeah he's gonna start then and and by
May 5th by the next day oh [__] they'll
they'll vote him out yeah it's all
[__] you're you're again you're if
that's the belief you're mired in
delusion you're mired in delusion you're
not understanding how the mechanisms
work you're not understanding what the
cult is doing why they're thinking the
way they're thinking why they're not
walking away from him and and crowding
around someone like Dan santis or Pence
or Christie or VC even Jesus Christ I
can't even believe I'm saying that about
Pence and VC but they're not they're not
gonna do it and I'm telling you if you
count on the justice system chuin or any
judge or Jack Smith or fonny Willis to
save our democracy if you're sitting
back relying on it which I don't think
everyone is I think some people are
cheering it but they know that they're
going to have to stay vigilant I'm just
saying we cannot expect what we think is
g to happen in March now to happen in
March when it comes around and the
reason why is because everyone thought
mayor garland would never prosecute
Trump oh he's not gonna do it he's not
and then he and then he got the special
counsel like oh but maybe not maybe not
and then they did and they indicted him
and it seems like Jack Smith is trying
to FastTrack Trump's trial right by just
convicting him or indicting him excuse
me in in DC whereas fonny Willis is
taking long game where she's willing to
go after every single one of these son
of a [__] in Georgia all 19 of them
and it's going to be a longer process in
Georgia than it is in the federal system
and I'm telling you there's a ton of
mechanisms and chuin has already told
Trump and I know she's not delaying but
Texas Paul she told Trump specifically
Loro in court his attorney he she said
if he keeps his p's and q's the way that
he should keep his PS and q's I will I
will give him the delays that he needs
to represent and I'm telling you Donald
Trump is going to take advantage
wherever he can and it's just gonna
happen yeah but I don't okay I'm gonna
disagree with you there here's the
reason all right so chudin chudin was
like look this is the date and we are
not this is this is what it's been
established this March 4th 2024 okay and
then Republicans and Donald Trump say oh
no no no this is this is political
interference this is political prose
ution this is a Witch Hunt you guys are
trying to influence the ballot by
putting me in a trial that starts the
day before again I just want to point
this out if you're innocent you've done
nothing wrong you have nothing to hide
you are being prosecuted legally and it
is unfair in any aspect then I would
hope that if those things are true for
you that you would want to have an early
as early as possible you don't want to
get that [__] out before anyone anyone
could have any sort of influence over
the ballots or or or over going into
vote if that's true but we know that's
not true because well again if there's
smoke there's fire and you know Donald
Trump's history and you know the crimes
that he's committed and I know he's
innocent till proven guilty but if you
look at all of these different
independent grand juries independent
investigations you have each of these
things that are happening they line up
to show you that Donald Trump through uh
through malicious intent tried to
overthrow the government and commit
these illegal Acts now when it comes to
judge chuin she
said she was like look this is the date
and John luro Trump's attorney said we
will abide by the decision that you have
given us right now as much as Donald
Trump wants to [__] and moan he goes
I'm gonna appeal you can't appeal and
even if you could appeal it is very very
difficult to even get that approved and
to have that actually
overturned so when she gives the date I
don't I don't at least as of right now I
don't anticipate any delays that are
going to happen on her end because she's
even said for it she's like look man
there's no reason that you should be any
different than any other person that
would be charged with these crimes just
because you're running for president
doesn't make it so that you can do it I
mean Bill bar went on Fox News after
Donald Trump went through 42 video rants
on Truth social and the first 31 the
final one that he did was attacking Bill
bar is slow and lethargic Bill bar being
allowed to go on Fox
News Bill bar was like uh well one he
was saying a very different tomb when he
was in office and two just because
you're running for office let's say
you're a mayor or something and someone
says here's a crime that you're being
charged with you can't come forward and
say well I should have special special
privileges because I'm running for this
office you don't have that ability so I
I don't I don't foresee any delays that
will happen where she's like okay great
yeah I'll give you another month or two
months because then if they do get into
any delays you have the issue of them
trying to then argue legally well we're
so close to the
election that it could be perceived that
it would have a negative effect on his
on his polling so I again I'm not a
lawyer right I'm just going based on
what she said and how John Loro his
attorney responded and how the facts of
having a delay just because you're
running for president because that seems
to be that that's a consistent kind of
thing that you hear within Maga and
Republicans he's running for president
do it after and he was like I want to
have in 2026 and she was like there's no
[__] reason for us toay another years
problem the problem with the 2026 thing
and the argument that Lura was making
because I read the transcript on that
point is Lara wasn't willing to give an
inch I think if Lara would have said
okay well then let's do it let's do it
in the beginning the spring of 2025 I
think chuckin would have pted it into
the fall of next year now Mar Margie
brings up a good point here this is one
of the things I love about the fuckum
fam she says even when we don't agree we
can still discuss things and it is
important that we do this that's why I
invite you guys here every day to have
this discussion these are my opinions
and I'm not always right I'm always
right um but I'm not always right I'm
always right um and we should probably
put this prediction in the doubt me on
the um on the Discord that rather this
the DC trial goes to trial on March 4th
I bet I'm going to be right but we'll
we'll see well maybe Tony dest was and
that's what they've been calling it over
there on the doubt me on Discord all my
predictions that I make um I I'm going
to be right about this one it's not
going to go to trial on March 4th this
is not the this is not
typical Federal proceedings but in
typical Federal proceedings they punt
the first trial date because of actual
delays and because there are actual
delays and and federal judges are very
apt to punt a trial for a delay they're
not you know kin's not going to bring a
trial where she thinks there could be an
appeal down the road because she didn't
give Credence to an actual delay she's
not going to do that and I believe chuin
is right down the middle um and that's
the good part about that case folks is
that chuin is the judge and she
understands not only the prosecution
side but the defense side so I I'm
reassured that no matter what happens
with that case if it goes to trial on
the fourth or gets punted If he if he's
in court and if he's in a criminal
courtroom before the election or after
the election I I believe that judge
shutkin is is the best judge for that
job even though she was drawn out of a
out of with a straw I believe she is the
best judge for that job so um and again
we have the right I want yeah I do want
yeah and but I do want to if there is
one other aspect to this if people
because I know that obviously you know
like with with Glenn and other people
you know there
are delusions of grand right on what we
would we would we would hope what we
expect what we would expect right what
we would expect in a
perfect judicial system that if someone
commits a crime that the correct people
are held accountable and they are
charged with um the the correct sensing
and we've been seeing this happening for
people like January 6 you know we're
gonna see
toio possible yeah and we're seeing
those things happen but I would also be
I'm also a little bit more
confident that you know any of these
cases because there's a lot of there's a
lot of you know again mag and
Republicans like oh Donald Trump's gonna
pardon himself he's gonna he's gonna do
it from the jail cell which makes no
[__] sense whatsoever it's really the
one the one I think it was Tim P when he
posted one of the photos of Donald Trump
the AI photo of him with like [__]
Nazi Eagle there oh the tattoo the the
the prison na the white supremacist yeah
yeah yeah so when I when I hear
arguments like that like Donald Trump's
going to Pardon himself this is what
Democrats are afraid of no we're
definitely not afraid of that AI version
of Donald Trump but two Trump pardoning
himself like one if he's got a pocket
pardon pull it out I want to see this
thing come out and or him try to claim
that he has it because then he would
have to admit that he committed a crime
because again a pardon is only used if
there was a crime that was committed if
you Comm committed a felony and you have
to go out and say oh man I knew what I
did was wrong and so I had to protect
myself a get out of jail free card you
have that one moment right there where
they go great okay so you've admitted
the fact that you knew that you stole
the documents or that you tried to
overturn the election or whatever but
when we go to Georgia that one I have a
lot more confidence one because state
level case but two because there are
people in there mark Meadows that seem
to be flipping and I wouldn't be
flipping he's like hey it was that guy
it was him it was him it was him it was
him he's like oh he would have yelled at
me he would have been so mad at me I'm
such I'm such a coward that I couldn't
even handle the presid of United States
to yell at me I had to commit sedition
right so you've got Mark Meadows who's
participating in Jack Smith's
investigation like all right I'm safe
there but on the state level charges I
have no way out the only way out is
to R you out I have to tell on you I
have to point the finger I have to be a
rat I have to snitch on you I have to do
whatever I can to save my own ass and
that's what and if there's anything if
there is any truth people like what's
what's the truth in life like what is
the purpose of life there is one truth
out there and you can always rely on
Donald Trump or Donald Trump's
Associates to rat on anyone else in
their party to get out of the [__] we
saw we saw him throw Eric Trump under
the bus where watching Mark Meadows do
it you're gonna see Sydney Powell I
don't know about Rudy Giuliani yet we
got Kenneth cheesbro who knows about uh
about uh Jeffrey Clark all of these
peopleon all people are gonna be
throwing these throwing these little
things out to be like well I wanna I
want to be able to to save my life
because there's no way I can get a
pardon right now which again goes to the
whole fact of like if you have a pardon
then you're admitting the fact that you
committed a
crime you dirty red you killed my
brother you dirty rat you dirty rat go
ahead text Paul and not only is this
trial going to go to go to trial quickly
because you know which one Willis fny
Willis down in Georgia which one fny
Willis is it's not it's that's that's a
legitimate question like which which one
because there's really good it seems
like Texas ball before you go on it
seems like there might be potential for
19 trials in Georgia but go ahead which
which one are you saying is going to go
fast uh Willis is is is every time she
goes into court she says the exact same
thing we're ready for trial today you
want to do it today we'll do it today we
are ready to go our Cas is is is
cemented the the uh Discovery is not
that in- depth they keep claiming it's a
million documents it is not a million
documents and we'll do this today and
she's pushing for a speedy trial I
guarantee you Trump is not going to get
away in Georgia with with delay delaying
these trials I guarantee it I will bet
you my hat he is not going to get away
with with delaying these trials and the
Beautiful part that you were talking
about Pardons and stuff man Georgia
Brian km cannot pardon Trump he cannot
just go out and pardon Trump there's a
commission and there is a guideline in
that commission that says you can't even
apply for a pardon for five years till
after you have you know why that is do
you know why that is in Georgia the
reason why that is because the the
pardon power was was was misused
crookedly now what happened was is
George is like well we can't have
Governors be doing this [__] so they
changed the Constitution and the law
what I was saying is that Brian Kemp
when he was giving the speech about it
he was leaving the door open that hey
Republicans just give me give me some
sort of power and I'll use it he was
leaving the door wide open he wasn't
saying hey just don't even [__] try
it don't even think about don't even
think about this being a possibility he
was like well I I don't I technically
right now in this moment as the
Constitution stands right now in Georgia
don't have this ability wink and if but
if I did I mean I guess I would consider
is what he was actually saying he was
asking the because the commission the
[__] commission that they have to try
to get rid of fonny Willis that didn't
[__] exists now it exists because
they're trying anything they can to
protect Trump anything they can I have
to being fact checked here um again live
in the chat it says Kagney never really
said that I think you're in you dirty
rat you dirty R you killed my brother H
I think some are saying that Kagney
never actually said that Gabe Sanchez is
like oh we're gonna [__] find that
fact that fact has a lot of r i wantan I
want to go to I want to and I know um
we're at the bottom of the hour so I
want to go to the enri enri tario um
this morning Scott McFarland filed this
report with CBS uh this morning warnings
uh this morning any wors for CBS Scott
McFarland's all over these cases the
January 6 so is Kyle Cheney um so I know
that we'll we'll see the results that is
happening in court today with Enrique
tario and his sentencing uh we'll see it
probably almost live on Twitter because
there's no cameras in federal courtrooms
but let's see what Scott has to I think
this was Scott um the former leader of
the farri proud boys is D to be
sentenced later today for his role in
planning the January 6 assault on the
capital prosecutors asking for the
longest prison sentence yet or enrick
Tero more than three decades Behind Bars
is what they want as Scott McFarland
reports they claimed that he was trying
to trigger a new American
Revolution arguing he deserves 33 years
in prison prosecutors say proud boy
leader Enrique tario was a charismatic
Savvy propagandist who had influence
over countless
subordinance tario wasn't at the capital
January 6th having been banned from
Washington DC while facing a previous
criminal
charge but prosecutors argue he helped
orchestrate organize and privately claim
credit for the assault on the capital
tiio and three of his fellow proud boys
were convicted of sedici conspiracy
plotting to use violence to block the
peaceful transfer of power defense
attorneys for some of taro's
codefendants argued former president
Donald Trump deserved more of the blame
and we're going to the capital for
encouraging his supporters to March to
the capital Where's Donald Trump in all
this he stood on the ellipse basically
told people 74 million of his followers
the election's stolen go to the go to
the capital Fight Like H you won't have
a country anymore the judge will
sentence tario today has handed down
prison terms that are just half of what
prosecutors have sought in the proud boy
cases so
far Dominic Piza a proud boy member who
breached the capital by Smashing a
window was convicted on charges
including assaulting a Federal Officer
on Friday he asked the court for
leniency arguing he'd given up politics
but moments the judge sentenced Piza to
10 years in prison and departed the
courtroom Piza lifted a fist and yelled
Trump
one 6 months from today Trump is
scheduled to be on trial at this
courthouse in his 2020 election
conspiracy case meanwhile this morning
jury selection Begins for Trump's former
trade advisor Peter Navaro in a contempt
of congress case he's charged with
snubbing a subpena last year from the
house select January 6 committee oh man
they're all on Criminal trial there in
Washington DC never stops this I got
this wronger there I thought it was Joe
bigs that did the fist pump and Trump
one but it was the the other [__] Joe
bigs cried like a little [__] right it
was the other [__] and not only that he
cried like a little [__] and then tried
to use his daughter as a prop to say I
have a daughter I'm supposed to be a
father well if that were the case then
you wouldn't have been there on January
6th you would have made sure that you
would have done whatever possible to
secure secure that position that you
have as her father so I don't mean I I
don't mean to laugh the Discord is
asking if Enrique tario is a top or a
bottom he's he's a he's a he's a ner
he's a ner Enrique tario is the one in
the corner that always wants to get in
on it and they say no no no once once
we're done once we finish and then just
just run the camera that's Enrique tario
Enrique tario isn't even a cuck he's the
guy that they force to film in the
corner that gets nothing oh so he's the
guy that stands behind the cook yeah
he's there like the cuck at least is on
camera being like oh this is my this is
my Kink this is what I like Enrique
tario is behind the camera the guy that
they shove in the corner and they're
like shut up don't speak just make sure
that's recording and get the angles
right is that zero days is that
technically Z I think technically
somebody one of you two said boner it
might have been you Tony I definitely
said boner I definitely said boner
because I think big step fan said uh in
the chat that we were back to zero when
I came back in after it was glitching I
came back in in it said zero days porn
yeah probably probably it was definitely
probably me who said boner I'm not going
to lie it's weird though it's weird that
all these Trump uh Trump Affiliates and
Trump Associates and and just Trump
himself keep having to go to court for
stuff it's so it's like they all I don't
know colluded to commit a crime a coup
if you will to try to stay in power for
another term even though he was a loser
and now they're all paying for it you
know you've got Peter Navaro who is the
the creator of the Green Bay sweep
you've got Joe bigs you've got uh uh
you've got the other proud boy that was
just there that was saying you know
Trump one does not age well at all uh
every one of these people thought that
they could get away with this and they
thought honestly that they were not
going to be held accountable for any of
the actions or any of the crimes that
they were you know going out in public
and doing doing well speaking of crimes
in public Mark Meadow said this on the
record in a federal courtroom Texas poll
he said what I didn't want to happen was
for the campaign to Prevail in court
action and not have this lined up he
said now what he's talking about is the
fake State electors and the meeting with
Brad rattis spat pburg down in Georgia
the prosecutor asked him in Cross
examination a simple question why why
would you want to do knew that because
he wasn't a member of the campaign he
was actually uh the white house chief of
staff which is not uh the campaign
there's two different universes there
are there supposed to be but in
Republican world they're the same thing
I I guess but
here's here was Mark meow's response to
the question why would you want to do
that why would you want to do that this
is his words this is the quote in open
court because I knew I'd be yelled at by
the president of the United States that
was his reason Texas Paul of why why he
would try to commit uh to overthrow an
election in a state because he would
Donald Trump would yell at
him what do you make of that what do you
make of that him saying that in open
Court Texas ball I he has spent the last
uh two you know prior to this everybody
did he flip didn't he flip is he
cooperating and then all of a sudden he
got all bold and [__] and then now that
he's in court
everything coming out of Mark Meadow's
mouth was it was him it was him it
wasn't me I didn't have anything to do
with this I didn't plan any of it I
wasn't involved you know I just all I
did was arrange the phone call that's my
job you know we don't even have
operators at the White House I gotta
make all the phone calls you know yeah
you think he was sitt he like a [__]
switchboard he's like you want okay got
it you got to do here I mean because we
have to remember Cassidy Hutchinson went
on record in her deposition and she
spoke in front of the Committee hearing
on the January 6 committee and she said
there was an evening before January 6
where I was with Rudy Giuliani and Mark
Meadows and we in the office and I I
walked Rudy Giuliani because you know
he's always drunk and moving around and
they had make sure that they got off the
actual him she had to carry him to the
car because here's the thing you can't
you can't trust Rudy Giuliani to
actually walk himself out of the
property he's like oh man I'm about to
lose my place so I gotta I gotta move in
here what they did was she walked him
she walked to the parking lot to the car
and he said he mentioned January 6th and
made comments about it and she walked
back in Mark Meadows on his little
[__] phone typing doesn't even look
at her Cassidy hudon says oh man it's
kind of crazy what Rudy Giuliani just
said he talked about January 6 they
trying to you know have this whole
demonstration and there's specifics that
I cannot remember right now but she was
she was talking about January 6th and
did not even did not even respond to her
and she was like markk did you hear what
I what I said Rudy Giuliani just said
this and he goes yeah you know something
we got to deal with you
know like he knew it was gonna happen
and he clearly knew he was like man we
have to we have to do this or else I'm
gonna get my [__] ass ripped open by
Donald he's gonna get yelled at by the
president listen Okay I I wanna first I
want to say this the everyone in that in
that group is a [__] ass [__] right
well and the biggest one is Donald Trump
that is the the the the consensus period
but here's the thing is that um when
you're in the White House and you're
chief of staff to the president United
States you are one of the first and last
stops to the President right who's
talking to him who's communicating with
him or her really it should be her we
should go to that pronoun for a
president United States just because
they would be much better at it it's
obvious um but here's the thing is that
the chief of staff is the first and last
ear and the first and last gatekeeping
to the president of United States now in
that the chief of staff has to be able
to push back on the president of the
United States that's the whole point of
being the chief of staff is to warn the
free leader of the Free World of risks
that are gonna come at them yeah just
like just like earlier Gabe challenged
me right he challenged me I I didn't
have a problem with him challenging me I
think he's wrong but he challenged me
we'll see we'll see we'll see time will
tell but think about the Dynamic inside
the Oval Office When Donald Trump was
pretending to be the president of the
United States that Mark Meadows Mark
Meadows knew that this was all [__]
just gonna blow up in their face Cassie
Hutchinson knew this I mean she was like
what the what the [__] are you talking
about hey Mark did you hear what he said
but and she tried to challenge and push
back him but Mark Meadows absolutely
would not push back on Donald Trump
because he might get a little loud he
might yell at
that is the cowardice that is the cow
and and honestly there is no better
reason to not vote for Republican ever
in any office there is than the
cowardice that they have in that Mark
Meadows thought to himself the reason
why I don't want to challenge the
president of United States when he is
wrong and I think and I know he's wrong
is because he'll get he'll yell at me
what the hell is wrong txas Paul is it
republicanism is it cowardice is it Mark
Meadows in general or what is it it
feels like to me that the the position
of the chief of staff is to push back on
the president when they're
wrong yeah and the the chief of staff
also has a canned answer for when the
president asked them to I don't know
arrange campaign phone calls they say
let me get your campaign manager on the
line
right pretty simple you can do that you
can do that the chief of staff does not
work for the campaign they don't act for
The Campaign but Mark Meadows is you got
to remember he was a republican
politician before he was Chief of Staff
I mean this guy is used to getting away
with bloody freaking murder he is and
and and he's just gonna sit there and
he's gonna try to pretend that oh my God
I was just so scared I was so scared
Donald Trump might get angry at me throw
some catchup my way you know no that
dude was all in man he was all in he was
you know what now that I think about
that maybe that's why Donald Trump would
only eat cheeseburgers alone cuz no one
wanted to be in the room cuz they're
like this guy's going to get pissed off
and he's going to throw cheeseburgers
and ketchup at me cheeseburgers and
Paradise you know having Donald having
cheeseburgers with Donald Trump would be
like having cheeseburgers in hell you
know that sounds that sounds like wanted
to get that sounds get me the diaper get
me the diaper that sounds Cheeseburgers
in Paradise that actually sounds like
the title of the Netflix series um the
the miniseries on the January 6
insurrection cheeseburgers it would be
cheeseburgers or cheeseburgers
Cheeseburgers in Paradise Cheeseburgers
in Paradise like that's the name of the
of the docu series The or maybe even the
you know the the dramatic rendition it
could be like a like a
um like part dramatization you know like
a true crime series kind of a dramy a
drama not a Dr a dram what they it's a
dramatization it's a docu series it's a
true crime series right yeah well part
of it true it's like historians telling
part of it and then and then they're
reenacting stuff but that's what cheese
cheeseburgers Cheeseburgers in Paradise
that's what it would be called um you
know to Jesus Christ I can't even
believe this is reality that we can
surmise these things live on myself on
the back I have been so well behaved we
have a couple turds floating in the bowl
in chat that have been running their
mouth and I have yelled at no one I'm
going to myself on the backat keep it
there that way I want you to yell at
Republicans not people in the chat at
least right now when I see someone I
might have you go after him um I want to
I want to point out something else our
friend um Chris Christopher Webb on
Twitter a friend of ours he he posted
this um report from Ali veli on MSNBC
alli's a I I actually this is one of the
ones on MSNBC that I think is a is a
warrior for democracy I think allly does
not mince words and he'll go after it
when he needs to go after and he defends
Democratic institutions where he needs
to when he's hosting his shows but this
this little section here is about how
Ohio Republicans and this goes back to
what Anna was saying earlier uh in the
vinmo chat and challenging me this is
what I go back to Republicans are trying
to change language in Ohio to confuse
people they can do this this is legal
stuff I mean you you really wouldn't
want to do it maybe unless you're trying
to convince people something that ain't
true but listen to this report about
what they're trying to do in Ohio to
take away women's healthare although
their attempt to raise the voting
threshold failed Ohio Republicans are
back at it again they're once again
employing manipulative tactics this time
the Republican controlled Ohio ballot
board is overhauling the summary that is
used to explain the amendment to voters
and instead introducing language that is
designed to confuse voters now I want to
show you this this I want to pause it
because I want you to look at this deis
here right and you you notice that
there's two women out of the six okay
but if you look right here on the end
and I'm not sure who this is but is this
person alive is this person even alive I
I can't even what in the [__] is going
on I can't understand this like this is
Mitch
McConnell um you know Ty what the [__]
is going
on how old is this person old enough
where posture isn't even a thing anymore
uh Jesus Christ this is one of those
things where yeah man this is this is a
demat or republican I have no idea if
this is a Democrat or Republican I
really don't oh my God is that
Yoda I'm telling you I'm telling you man
what's the name what's the name of this
committee um [__] hang on a second let
me see if I can track that down uh let's
see it is it is the uh Ohio ballot board
is um and it's Republican controlled of
course so I'm assuming I'm assuming that
the old yodu figure here on the end is
Ohio ballot board me okay all right I'm
looking I'm looking looking yeah okay
well you go ahead and look let's let's
listen to the rest of the report from
Ally the revised summary borrows
language from the anti-abortion
movements playbook for instance it
replaces the scientifically accurate
term fetus which we all know with the
emotionally charged term unborn baby the
term unborn baby gives the false
impression that the fetus could survive
outside the womb when in reality that is
not possible until the very final stage
of a fullterm pregnancy so basically
what they're doing and he continues here
about more delusion that they're putting
on the bound because it's just not true
like they're putting [__] on the ballot
to confuse voters and more more than
anything confuse voters who might have a
tendency to say you know what I'm for
women getting health care but I'm not
for abortion up to birth right because
it'll explain here how they're changing
that language and the unborn baby or
unborn child is important as the fetus
let's listen but the revised language is
not designed to be medically accurate
it's meant to be emotionally
manipulative they've also replaced the
term decision with medical treatment
have included wording falsely suggesting
that the amendment would quote always
allow an unborn child to be aborted at
any stage of pregnancy end quote that's
misleading that misleading description
Taps into the fear-mongering rhetoric
around later stage abortions despite the
fact that that procedure is exceedingly
rare
exceedingly rare fewer than 1% of
abortions in the United States occur at
or after 21 weeks and in almost all
cases they involve heartbreaking
situations such as severe fetal
anomalies or medical conditions
threatening the woman's life according
to the Kaiser Family Foundation uh so
there you go um there's alli's report
and thank you Ally and thank you for uh
Chris Christopher Webb pointing it out
uh on Twitter and giving us that clip um
because it's very important to stay
vigilant in these ways that's why say
you know I understand how Sensational it
is to be like yeah Donald Trump's going
to go to federal trial on March 4th and
that's really cool and all and we want
to stay you know focused on that but
here's the thing it's like are you
reading about this
guy I'm trying to you I I'll send it in
the chat uh okay but I'm I'm reading
about the I'm trying to find the guy I
just keep finding photos of this
committee uh and I think I know who it
is but you can show the photo later so
so anyways um but we have to stay
V all right I'm going I'm going to show
the audience this sorry I was gonna
finish I was gonna finish I was gonna
finish my thought
but sorry oh my God he's just kind of is
this an official picture of them yeah
this is them
hear oh my god look man if you can't I
there's something to be said here like
if I'm not saying if you're that old but
if you're having you know hard time
hearing the arguments or seeing the
arguments from a person that's
presenting
them the guy's got the guy's got a name
tag in front of his face man like he's
already right well here's the thing is
like they're determining they're they're
like determining language on unborn
children versus fetus yeah is this this
is this a is this a living breathing
human up there or did they just throw a
dead carcass up there this is ridiculous
am I off my rocker what who is this like
I've got Bill Bill Morgan is what it
says on the tag I don't know if that's
actually the the dude's name wait wait
wait wait wait wait so you're saying
like Bill Morgan exist but they're like
well we can't get the real Bill Morgan
in here so bring in bring in one of them
uh them cadavers to stand in for bill is
that what's going on here I don't know
I'm trying to find a photo that has a
clear Jus [__] Christ well it could
actually hold on let's see it could be
yeah it could be Bill Morgan because he
if he sits to the left or the right
depending on where you look of Teresa
gavorin gavon Gavin gavon anyway that's
what the name tag says Bill Mor it does
so if I go because I went to the website
and on there the thing is every other
one of these names you could easily just
Google okay you could throw it into
Google image search and then you'll find
the face that comes with it right but in
here because you've got the honorable
Frank lose chairperson The Honorable
Teresa gavon the woman The Honorable
Paula Hicks Hudson William M Morgan you
search for that
dude you know buildings you know I swear
to God it's just buildings ain't it part
of like a vampire lore that you can't
take pictures of them because they can't
see themselves in mirrors and [__] and
that and actually you know what actually
I just found an image okay all right
here we go here we go is this is this
from um current or is this from like 30
years ago when he was only 438 when he
looked like he could stand up
straight I'm just saying that's I'm just
I'm just going based on the photo I'm
not judging or anything I'm just going
based on the photo these are my comment
here you know you know what's crazy is
that um we hear this all the time from
the right where they're like Joe Biden
this and Joe Biden that and I don't
really bring up Joe Biden that much or
this this ages and stuff but Jesus
[__] Christ man if MCH McConnell
can't stand in front of a microphone
without glitching and this guy can't sit
up straight why in the [__] are they
governing and setting policy here's
here's here's William Morgan
here um I I found a modern I found a
recent photo that's 2017 so this is five
years ago that's five years ago godamn
that's before somebody in the chat hold
on somebody in the chat I found one from
last week if you is that is that the one
oh you found from last week okay yeah
okay let's see let's see this is
um you're so [__] full of
[__] you got to show him
[Laughter]
now oh my God oh my God what in the [__]
why are
we that dude it looks like him I'm not
gonna lie that [__] looks like him I
love I love uh the just the URL has Star
Wars fleshy Yoda human skin fan
art
[Laughter]
[__] [__] me [__] me running what in the
[__] actually this guy looks younger
than the guy in the on the board to be
quite honest yeah this we have to
remember that Yoda is hundreds of years
old he looks only like this for his age
so he looks pretty good honestly right
right this this Yoda looks pretty good
compared to Bill Bill
Morgan there on the Ohio ballot board I
couldn't just I just don't my guess is
is that Bill Bill Morgan is is a [__]
stuff shirt Republican when do you want
to I would I would absolutely I would
absolutely agree with that it's also
funny because like you you se you just
like Googling M William andg oh man I
can't but trying to find trying to find
this guy in Google search you can only
find one photo and then once you find
one then it'll relate it to other ones
but like even on the first page there's
like one if you got a girl you got
another man you got an old painting a
dude with a horse a guy that's way
younger then you have an architect then
you have an actor then you have uh
histor a prehistoric architecture and
it's
like oh my God either the name is super
common or this guy has been flying under
the radar this whole [__]
time
Jesus Paul Young's commenting Chad is
priceless speaking of flying you will
not oh my God speaking of flying under
the thanks Paul for your comment Paul
Young laugh you will not um speaking of
flying under the radar one last Quick
Clip before we go how in the [__] did I
miss this from April this clip here of
marjerie Taylor green how in the [__]
did I miss this clip she's talking she's
talking about the Ice Age here listen to
this [__] how did I miss this people are
not affecting climate change yeah you're
going to tell me that back in the Ice
Age how much taxes did people pay and
how many changes did governments make to
melt the
ice what what would as Gabe would say
what what was
that I'm not [__] you she said this
in a goddamn meeting back in April how
did I miss this Asian poster let me play
it again people are not affecting
climate change you're going to tell me
that back in the Ice Age how much taxes
did people pay and how many changes did
governments make to M this does sound
familiar I feel like I did
oh my God what in the actual [__] is she
talking about yeah this [__] makes no
sense obviously but uh I'm trying to
remember if this was on her run when she
was going after Joe Biden for I feel
like if I remember correctly yeah this
was around the same time that she was
making claims of fentel against Joe
Biden and then she got fact checked and
tried to use that mother as a prop and
say it was Joe Biden's border that
caused the fenel coming in my son's died
and then she got fact was like actually
her son's died sadly in 2020 and who is
president Donald Trump well let me
finish the clip because it gets Dumber
you're like whoa how is that possible
the is it the squirrel from the movie
Ice Age that caused the mown to happen
guess I guess so I don't know if she's
watching too many cartoons or what but
listen the climate is going to continue
to change and there is no reason to just
open up our borders and allow everyone
in and continue to funnel over $50
billion dollar or however many billions
of dollars or trillions of dollars to
foreign countries all over the world
simply because they don't like the
climate change God does she wait hold on
on she turned this into a border thing
what the does she think that climate
change happens in like yes you know you
know what this makes me think God damn
it now I'm gonna have to do a [__]
what with that because now this makes me
think of the time that Hershel Walker
said that China had bad air and we had
good air right and they're sending their
bad over a over they're sending their
bad over here and taking our good air
over there with them
balloons my God the werewolf Sheriff man
the werewolf can't believe I missed yeah
go ahead just a PSA if you actually paid
attention in science class we had an Ice
Age over a meteor we had an Ice Age over
mini Ice Age over volcanoes because they
you know we had a a lot of tectonic
activity they dumped a shitload of
carbon in the atmosphere all at one time
and it triggered an Ice Age the one
we're having that's starting now that
they're tracking and they're saying no
really people we're we're about to go
into an Ice Age they're tracking because
of us [__] we're doing no volcanoes no
[__] meteors have hit the earth and
caused an ice age it's us and we can
change that we can fix that no matter
how much taxes much taxes Jesus Christ
you know people are paying or what you
don't want to believe in policies or
whatever because it doesn't [__]
matter if you believe it or not I say
just don't give a [__] if you believe in
it or not it's going to freeze your
little blue balls off
anyways that's going to happen that's a
good point and it comes back to science
you know something else that doesn't
care about who you support in the
election or what your part of party
affiliation is what's that uh coid
viruses things like that so Donald Trump
he's like they're not going to lock down
again [__] you lock down the
country in 2020 you're the one who did
that but in his 31 video rant that he
did he was like Joe Biden and the
Democrats are going to try to lock down
G whiz you know what's coming up in
election that no they're not gonna do
that man they're not gonna do that sh
it's crazy [__] only question Fe Fe the
only question that comes to mind uh that
I want to know uh about this clip about
marcha Taylor green the question I would
want to ask her is who is president
during the last ice age it's probably
Obama thank Obama uh make sure to go
make sure to go make sure to go visit
real texas.com the link is down below go
watch Texas Paul show tomorrow morning
before our show watch on Sunday as well
and we got some news Gabe Sanz we got
some news coming about expansion of the
Tony Michaels podcast and the Tony
Michaels podcast Universe coming
tomorrow so don't forget to tune in
tomorrow me and Gabe Sanchez have some
big announcements of stuff that's going
to happen next week that's right next
week there's going to be some changes
and expansion here at Tony Michael's
podcast so don't forget to go over to
what wassh show.com or
patreon.com gab Sanchez support him
there and again go to real texas.com
down below visit my patreon page if you
want to hit subscribe here on the
YouTube channel because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment of the
Tony Michaels podcast no matter what
Yoda pictures we pull up or who we're
bashing Jesus Christ there's always
something going on yesterday Boston
Brian jumps in uh unexpectedly and then
today we we get Yoda come in so same
time same place
tomorrow surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fit and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
we take our next steps into the world
you must go forth into the world it is
with passion passion courage of
conviction courage in your conviction
and most importantly most importantly
have faith in yourself be true to
yourself we did it I did it we take our
next steps into
the